[Musica]
ogni tanto mi flash no davanti alla
faccia tutte quelle cose che da piccolo
mi terrorizzavano in televisione una tra
tutte era la sigla di xfiles ma è anche
banale a credo abbia traumatizzato
chiunque quella legge poi c'erano cose
un pochino più specifiche per esempio la
musica che suonava durante i video del
logo dell'unione europea pan pan
para io scappavo ero terrorizzato da
quella cosa lì ci sono delle canzoni per
esempio atlantic dei keane che mi
mettono in uno stato positivo di ansia
ma che sia uno stato di ansia positivo
l'ho capito adesso quando ero piccolo
mica cavo nelle mutande poi uno si
chiede perché io sia finita in queste
condizioni è un'altra cosa che mi teneva
sveglio la notte era ultimo minuto e io
lo so che soltanto avendo nominato il
nome ad un sacco di voi vi sarà tornata
in testa una carrellata di immagini che
vi ha raggelato il sangue per tutti gli
altri che non sanno di cosa stia
parlando
ultimo minuto era un programma su rai3
che è andato in onda tra il 1993 e il
1997 in questo programma c'era un po di
tutto in questo studio c'erano i
conduttori è insieme a degli ospiti a
volte persone comuni a volte dei vip si
discuteva di situazioni al limite a
volte si vedevano dei filmati un po al
real tv quindi filmati di telecamere di
sicurezza registrati da videocamere
visto che siamo negli anni 90 a volte
c'erano delle candid camera dove
venivano messi alcuni ignari passanti in
condizioni di finto pericolo ma quello
che mi ha fatto fare incubi per tutti
gli anni delle medie erano le
ricostruzioni per farvi capire lo shock
psicologico che abbiamo subito in quegli
anni di tutto quello che vi ho
raccontato le candid camera gli ospiti
gli invitati e i conduttori nessuno si
ricorda niente del programma tutti si
ricordano solo delle ricostruzioni
perché erano la parte più realistica e
cruda di tutto il programma un po per
raccontarlo a voi un po per esorcizzare
questa mia paura che mi porto dietro da
30 anni ho voluto passare un'intera
settimana a guardare tutte le
ricostruzioni che ho trovato su internet
è incredibilmente su youtube è pieno e
non dimentichiamoci di una cosa
fondamentale
questo programma in soli cinque anni
ebbe un successo stratosferico e non
vuoi che venga copiato il format e lo
voi che mediaset copy il format per
capitalizzare un po su tutto il pubblico
ma nessuno di quei programmi ebbe lo
stesso successo o meglio quasi tutti
perché c'è una cosa che probabilmente
avuto addirittura più successo della
fonte originale ed è la parodia di aldo
giovanni e giacomo degli svizzeri il 99
per cento di voi sicuramente saprà che
gli svizzeri sono una parodia di ultimo
minuto ma per quell'uno per cento che
proprio enorme a rivedere ecco un colpo
di scena tu immagina ideare non solo
degli sketch comici ma un intero
spettacolo comico parodia di un
programma drammatico e fargli avere più
risonanza nel corso degli anni della
fonte originale
follia e sai chi ti potrebbe salvare
all'ultimo minuto zoom drammatico
norma donna nord di pm nord viene mi ha
salvato un qualcuno quando guardavo
ultimo minuto in treno ma ne parliamo
poi dopo quindi questo è un piccolo
riassunto della settimana che ho passato
a guardare ultimo minuto
[Musica]
siamo in sardegna è tutta la storia è in
realtà il flashback un flashback del
signor oneda o meglio viene chiamato
cionet da che vuol dire l'agnello e
racconta questa storia racconta che
quando era giovanissimo lavorava insieme
a due persone chiamate saldatore e maria
salvatore maria a un certo punto
decidono di portare uno dei loro tory al
macello in macelleria in città solo che
per loro è la prima volta non hanno mai
portato un toro legato da qualche parte
quindi non sono molto abili ai mezzi in
quel periodo sono quel che sono quelli
li legano due corde letteralmente al
collo e alle corna e uno da una parte e
uno dall'altra tirando lo portano avanti
il toro è progettato ma comunque
riescono a tenerlo a bada ma quando si
avvicinano al macello il toro sente
l'odore del sangue e da un'inquadratura
riesce anche a vedere dei pezzi di carne
abbastanza lontani un po dubbia come
cosa carica e colpisce salvatore in un
modo non proprio identificato adatterà
il robot guerino e si ama di s.salvatore
perdono la corda perché intorno
impazzisce e inizia a correre da tutte
le parti seminando il terrore di cinque
bambini che scappano a destra sinistra
adulti che non sanno dove mettersi si
arrampicano sui cancelli sui muri c'è
questa povera signora che al tempo della
registrazione delle pisodio era ancora
viva cade dalla sedia di schio poverina
giù da un dirupo ma maria che non voleva
mollarlo questo cazzo di toro lo
acchiappa dall'unica corda rimasta e
tenta di fermarlo ma poverina non ci
riesce cade faccia a terra e viene
trascinata e la corda le si stringe al
polso quindi poverina si fa tipo 125 km
a faccia a terra nel cioccolato salvo
non si riesce a fermarlo finché non
arriva daniele il protagonista che sta
raccontando questa storia prima di tutto
salva maria perché alla città in mano
detto mentre guardavo l'episodio ma non
taglia la testa al toro lo tagliamo il
tar non lo so in realtà colpisce la
corda e la stacca e per un attimo ho
pensato tra di esse le mani di maria è
un attimo e poi in realtà no e poi mi
sono chiesto e mo che fasto poveraccio
come fa a fermare gli sparerà limpidi
taglierà una zampa poverino lo farà
cadere non lo so no tranquillamente si
sfidano a duello tipo sergio leone non
prende per le corna in cina un po la
testa e lo sbatte a terra con una
facilità estrema ha disarmato il toro
tanto che dopo i titoli di coda è
arrivato i fiori a chi a fargli una
proposta sono a malapena le otto del
mattino e ci appartiamo la grana
[Musica]
l'ascensore i ghiotti né probabilmente
uno degli episodi più in crisi non è il
mio preferito quello arriverà
probabilmente uno degli episodi più di
tutti c'è questa signora teresa in
questo palazzo di 19 piani che vuole
trasferirsi perché c'è troppo rumore il
suo palazzo ci sono sempre lavori the
schiamazzi e lei non ce la fa più non
riesce più a dormire poverina non ci fa
dormire
a un certo punto un altro inquilino di
nome giorgio il cui hobby è quello di
riparare il vano ascensore o cinesi oggi
vuole dedicarsi al suo hobby molto
speciale la manutenzione degli ascensori
e
il suo hobby quando leggo niente da fare
decide di riparare ascensori così per
per divertimento era imparato guardando
altre persone come si fa ha imparato
osservando i tecnici al lavoro e siccome
lui ha imparato un po come non so se ve
lo ricordate il film d'arti martina arti
marziali chocolate dove c'è questa
ragazza autistica che impara tutte le
arti marziali semplicemente guardando i
film di bruce lee altezza senza alcuna
preparazione atletica è giorgio uguale
giorgio un certo punto decide siccome
non ha niente da fare di sistemare il
vano ascensore e tra l'altro lui ha le
chiavi della sala macchine
dell'ascensore al diciannovesimo piano
perché è riuscito a farsele dare perché
il fondi e quello ed è riuscito a
procurarsi le chiavi del vano motore al
diciannovesimo piano e siccome il suo
giorno libero palesemente decide di fare
questo ambaradan con la felpa addosso
con scritto sex a caratteri cubitali
rossi si ficca con meta corpo a fare
qualcosa nel vano ascensore e qualcuno
da sotto lo chiama e inizia la
catastrofe parte dell'ascensore gli
recide la giugulare e il incastra la
testa tra
l'ascensore è il vano dell'ascensore e
c'è questa inquadratura da dentro il
vano dell'ascensore lontano di questa
testa piccolina sporca di sangue tutta
storta lui per ovvie ragioni
agitatissimo inizia a sbattere mani e
piedi con questo corpo incastrato
e colpisce anche la porta della signora
teresa che incazzata dice mo basta io
voglio dormire
apre la porta e vede questo corpo tutto
sporco di sangue incastrato sotto del
sensore video inizia a chiamare i
pompieri diciamo urlare come una matta
esce fuori può giustamente nel panico ma
una tragedia tremenda e la signora
teresa ha salvato giorgio che era
poverino in fin di vita poi lo forte
fino in ospedale grazie a dio lo salvano
dio mio
allora facciamo una premessa io non so
quanto possa ridere o prendere per il
culo queste ricostruzioni perché appunto
sono ricostruzioni sono cose che sono
realmente successo quindi tenterò di
raccontarvi l'applicare incastrata nei
binari senza vivere il protagonista il
signor giuseppe il proprietario di un
apecar lui soffre d'asma e con la sua
applicar va in farmacia e prende le
medicine ecco questo dettaglio
completamente inutile però c'è e il
prologo di tutta la storia dopo aver
preso le medicine probabilmente per il
viaggio che fai sono le cinque di
pomeriggio
non te lo devi un cicchetto non te lo
fai un trinchetto due dita di vino sono
le cinque del pomeriggio lui entra in un
bar alle cinque di pomeriggio e ne esce
a notte fonda quindi è un attimo
stralunato dai fumi dell'alcol
il signor giuseppe mentre sta tornando a
casa il narratore tn a dirci che il
signor giuseppe a causa dell'alcol e
della stanchezza a
numerosi colpi di sonno alla guida e i
continui attacchi di sotto degli anni
piano la vista di un colpo di sonno
vuoi il vino buono vuoi il liquore vuoi
l'ammazzacaffè vuoi un po di stanchezza
durante questo dormiveglia desio
giuseppe che si sveglia dorme si sveglia
dorme non so che tipo di viaggio
chiamato in un paesello che più buio di
così non c'era imbocca una strada gira a
sinistra imbocca una strada ma purtroppo
non è una strada
quelli sono i binari è il destino vuole
che si addormenti proprio lei sui binari
del treno cambio scena c'è un casellante
che sta lavorando proprio lì in un
casello li vicino in quel momento lì
stava facendo un cruciverba non c'entra
assolutamente niente con la storia ma ce
l'hanno detto anche più volte hanno
spinto su questa cosa che il casellante
stesse facendo il cruciverbone
fa vedere anche che sottolinea una delle
domande che risponde in modo corretto
con toro alla domanda all'inizio sembra
non accorgersi di nulla il tempo stringe
ma all'improvviso negli ultimi 20
secondi riesce a correre a tirare via il
signor giuseppe ea salvarlo da morte
certa
io mi immagino il signor giuseppe
svegliarsi ubriaco marcio come una
locomotiva che non si ricorda nulla e
dettaglio importante gli altri
passeggeri del treno che giustamente si
è fermato con l'ape car schiacciata
sotto che gli chiedono ma come sta gli
danno pacche sulla spalla tutti
preoccupati gli offrono da bere di tutto
e al casellante niente non glie ne
sbatte il cazzo a persona che si abbassa
la troika tanto che noi no dice
nell'intervista è che io ho anche letto
la trentina qualcosa da verità scene che
non sta in piedi dalle elezioni poesia
riguardando gli episodi una cosa che mi
ha fatto impazzire
e proprio la qualità e la passione che
ci hanno messo a ricostruire l'intera
storia in 7 8 minuti vi di dvd filmato
c'è cuore la regia molto spesso
soprattutto per fare determinate cose
molto difficili come l'inseguimento di
un toro e assurda certo la recitazione
lascia un pochino a desiderare la gente
presa dalla strada credo ma poche volte
guardando nascerà ho detto questo e
proprio spazzature a livello di
produzione anzi e infatti ho scoperto
leggendo un po di ultimo minuto che uno
dei registi di queste ricostruzioni era
gabriele muccino prima di diventare
famoso diciamo cazzo e come si spielberg
avesse diretto tre o quattro episodi di
paperissima sprint lo riguarderà i
volentieri con più attenzione anche
probabilmente
[Musica]
dunque il dramma della persiana questa
signora la signora si balla è una
casalinga un po annoiata che sta facendo
ha avuto le faccende di casa sua
e mentre stira sta guardando questa
televendita ricostruita che se infatti
palese mese è tutto finto parcheggiato
davanti a un termosifone che sta
vendendo di una spazzola elettrica per
pulire casa sì ma non vuole farsi
perdere questa occasione irripetibile
costa anche poco quindi la contra
immediatamente è la usa per pulire le
persiane dentro e fuori
quindi si arrampica sulla finestra di
una delle due pressione e metà dentro
metafore inizia a pulirla ma purtroppo è
difettosa infatti la presa elettrica
inizia a fare uso ibiza c'è uno scoppio
della spatola lei si spaventa
cade e rimane attesa
[Musica]
e nessuno la sente da nessuna parte una
segretaria che stava lavorando ai doppi
metri e non sente nulla il vicino di
casa stava usando la falciatrice emesso
il 3 luglio grazie a dio una delle sue
vicine esce sul balcone per stendere i
panni e la vede e c'è questa scena
bellissima dalla signora che si spaventa
è la prima cosa che fa vedendo separa
pesa e chiamarla umana sembra ma che
cazzo fai made in giù ma che cazzo fai
sentendo tutto questo fracasso
finalmente il signore con la falciatrice
se ne accorge e inizia a correre nel suo
palazzo intanto anche la moglie della
signora capelli ne riparli esce un po
scazzato con la voglia dicendo cosa che
cosa vuoi cosa c'è
stavo guardando il mercoledì di coppa
cosa vuoi che corre anche lui a salvare
se i bagni ma purtroppo nessuno sa per
suonando al citofono quindi iniziano a
breve lo senza sosta tipo di tanino e
finalmente la segretaria scassatissima
riesce ad alzarsi e di nilmar banchiere
apre la porta loro salgono e riescono a
salvare silvana quindi amici ascoltatori
la morale dell episodio è le televendite
sono una truffa
l'episodio che abbiamo visto perché ho
fatto vedere l'episodio che lei che non
aveva mai visto ultimo non risposero il
titolo perché l'inizio e piero di twist
vuoi raccontare
allora c'è standard che si è sposata 16
anni ea una bambina e sembrano
informazioni di lusso
perché si annoia perché giustamente a 16
anni che non 30 a 16 anni e già una
donna sposata annoiata a casa che stia
con la figlia la figlia e decide di
prendere le chiavi della macchina del
marito che andato al lavoro che di
andare a guidare e mentre fruga nelle
tasche del marito del giubbotto per
cercare le bugie le chiavi una bambina
decide già con gli istinti suicidi di
prendere le la prolunga iniziare a
giocare con la prima mela corrente e tu
sei lì che dici a e questo l'incidente
della monta da no no no ovest arriva
standard che mai
dopo aver preso la bambina decide di
prendere la macchina e iniziare a
guidare anche se non sa farlo infatti si
vede le compresa 126 mezza incastrata
dei pozzi che frena e accelera così e tu
dici è cade giù da un burrone e invece
no il marito scopre che lei guida di
nascosto e decide di nasconderle le
chiavi invece riportarseli alla loro
storia
e li trova nelle tazzine
della grand am ma prende la macchina e
desidera trovare il suocero per pranzo e
certo punto si trova in questo incrocio
con la statale di pieno di macchine lei
va in avanti c'è un furgone che frena
male pippo ha dato alla macchia tu dici
è l'incidente e colorare l'incidente
alla puntata no no non è quello che va
dal
suo cielo che sta preparando il
minestrone ci ha tenuto a dirci
tagliandole portata
se l'ho ripetuto più volte
che scende dalla macchina ma si
dimentica essendo alle prime armi di
tirare il freno a mano quindi la
macchina inizierà andare in retromarcia
verso un burrone infinito con la bambina
ancora sul sfide e lei in impari
catalizza cercare di fermare la macchina
si mette dietro la macchina per fermarla
ma ovviamente non ci riesce la macchina
la investe in pieno la tira un altolà
scartavetra per terra la disintegrato
poverina è ovviamente come in ogni buona
episodio di ultimo minuto urlava e
nessuno lo sa perché non mentre tagliava
le patate sentiva la tv la radio kiss e
già lei a terra con la macchina addosso
che urla la bambina di piange e la
macchina appesa su questo burrone tipo
da un palo e si piega tema di più
finalmente il suocero la sempre corre
fuori a salvarla poverina e fa la cosa
che meno devi fare in un incidente
stradale di gente con le ossa rotte e
che inizia la prende dalle spalle inizia
attirarla ma come la strattona dicendo
vacanza non si muove perché era
incastrata la voglia e poi anche detto
tipo no sicuro aveva qualcosa di rotto
perché non si muoveva si gela uccisa tu
è colpa tua solleva la macchina tira
fuori lei l'appoggio al muro va a
prenderla sua macchina arriva lì la
carica lei in macchina e il graziadio si
ricorda che c'erano le quote che urlava
dentro nella macchina che stava
precipitando e salva anche questi fake
out di trama li hanno messi apposta
perché gli altri episodi erano più
noiosi allora non ha detto sai cosa
faccio ti faccio che il download però su
youtube si chiama brescia donna vestita
e quindi non vi nego che è stato più
divertente del previsto fare questa
settimana solo di ultimo minuto sia
perché molto probabilmente le mie paure
erano fondate sul fatto che io fossi
molto piccolo e che il il mood di queste
ricostruzioni era tendenzialmente molto
drammatico e ansiogeno
ma non vi ho parlato del mio episodio
preferito c'è un signore vagamente
ispirato ad un osservatore di fringe che
deve prendere il treno e a parte
attraversare i binari quando non
dovrebbe sembra un signore normalissimo
arriva all'inter siti che deve prendere
si vede che sono gli anni 90 ma nessuna
delle porte della prima classe si apre
quindi è anche un po schifato lo deve
salire dalla seconda classe dai poveri
braccianti massa fino alla prima classe
e si siede insieme agli altri lui doveva
scendere la fermata di padova ma
purtroppo si addormenta non si accorge
che ormai la sua cabina è vuota quindi
all'improvviso apri gli occhi prende la
valigia prende il cappello e cerca di
scendere ma nessuna delle porte si apre
l'unica porta che riesce a trovare
aperta è quella non dal lato della
banchina ma quella dal lato dei binari
ma aggrappato alla vaniglia scende dal
treno all'ultimo minuto quindi le porte
si chiudono e il suo braccio rimane
incastrato e il treno parte con lui
appeso inizia ad urlare come un pazzo e
nessuno l'ho sempre
nessuno si accorge di niente il treno
sta in grande velocità e c'è questa
splendida scena della gente alla
stazione e il treno che passa dietro con
lui che gli corre dietro il braccio
a un tempismo comico involontario che mi
passion dosso ogni volta che lo vedo ma
grazie a dio due agenti delle forze
dell'ordine lo vedono e iniziano a
correre dietro il treno a correre dietro
il treno ma sono matti nel frattempo il
signore non solo ha perso il cappello
non solo la valigia si è aperta e ha
perso tutto il contenuto ma perdente i
pantaloni
e perché è una delle cose più infantili
del mondo ridere a un uomo che perde i
pantaloni troppo lui in una delle
situazioni di pericolo più impossibili
nella vita egli calano le braghe così
mentre sta andando avanti con i
poliziotti nero li seguono
dall'incastro
sono 50 gradi qui dentro non ce la posso
fare
che poi mi dispiace perché è una storia
vera c'è anche un vero signore che parla
nella ricostruzione mi dispiace però
fatto le giuro su dio è uno degli
episodi che il mio preferito suddetto ma
grazie a padre pio
una signora da dentro il treno vede il
braccio incastrato inizia ad urlare
riescono a tirare con altri ragazzi
tirare il freno d'emergenza
frenano sto benedetto treno è il signore
è salvo e questo signore è superman ma
complimenti alla forza fisica di
quest'uomo
d'animo è incredibile ma anche la sua
forza fisica non è niente male
complimenti non ce la faccio non ce la
faccio io vi ringrazio per aver sentito
delirare me vedere me in una settimana a
guardare solo ultimo oh mio dio
adesso non riuscirà più dalla testa per
un altro mese e mezzo
cazzo
sai cosa avrebbe dovuto fare quel
signore per per evitare questo problema
come ho fatto io quando sono andato sul
treno avere nord vpn nel suo portatile
che c'è e grazie a loro in viene non
solo non mi incastro con il braccio
dentro un intercity
ma se mi vogliono connettere youtube per
guardare un episodio di ultimo minuto
tipo il bambino che cade in una fossa
romana perché stava andando a recuperare
un pallone mi permette di proteggere i
miei dati quando mi connetto alle reti
pubbliche e ti permette ovviamente di
connetterti ad un ip diverso dalla tua
nazione per poter per esempio comprare
dei biglietti di un intercity per padova
e come al solito trovate qui e in
descrizione il codice sconto yotobi e mi
raccomando state attenti con le
tapparelle
il signor rezzonico è costretto in casa
da una fastidiosa infezione pennica